Trascrizione: Manuela Sagliocco
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Tempo fa, ho chiesto a mia madre
che tipo fossi da bambina.
Lei mi ha risposto:
“Be’, è passato tanto tempo,
ma c'è una cosa che ricordo molto bene:
che avevi una forte avversione
per i luoghi bui”.
Vi sembrerà strano, ma questa è la ragione
per cui, 18 anni fa, ho preso
una macchina fotografica in mano.
Ho iniziato a fotografare da giovanissima:
avevo qualcosa da dire,
ma non ero in grado
di esprimerlo a parole.
Sono sempre stata negata con la scrittura,
infatti non vi nascondo
che anche per preparare questo discorso
ho passato tantissime notti insonni.
Parlo meglio per immagini,
e la fotografia per me
è sempre stata come una penna,
una penna con cui
sto scrivendo il mio racconto.
Spesso, infatti,
quando rivedo le mie prime fotografie
è come leggere le pagine
di un diario che non ho mai scritto.
Questo diario inizia
quando, con la mia famiglia,
mi sono trasferita in una nuova casa.
Di quel periodo non ho
un ricordo molto vivido,
forse perché non è stato tra i più felici.
Infatti tendevo a passare
molto tempo da sola,
e la maggior parte di questo tempo
lo trascorrevo proprio
all'interno della nuova casa.
In principio, però, non la sentivo mia.
Così, per creare un legame,
ho preso la macchina fotografica
e ho iniziato a fotografarmi
ad ogni angolo,
ad allestire dei piccoli set,
a ricreare delle situazioni surreali.
Forse stavo sfuggendo dalla realtà;
o forse stavo semplicemente creando
un mondo in cui poter vivere,
un luogo per me.
Ho fatto tutto questo
ogni giorno, per tre anni.
E così, da luogo sconosciuto
la casa è diventato il set
della mia prima serie fotografica.
Era come se, grazie alla fotografia,
stessi pian piano facendo luce
su quegli angoli bui
che da piccola tanto temevo.
Passati tre anni, però, mi sono detta:
basta, devo uscire, devo vedere
cosa c'è oltre queste mura.
E così sono uscita,
e ho iniziato a fotografare Latina,
la Provincia dove sono cresciuta.
Questa volta partivo da un luogo
che conoscevo molto bene,
ma che ho riscoperto sotto una nuova luce:
quella delle albe di agosto,
quando la città è deserta,
le strade sono vuote,
e ti ritrovi improvvisamente
a essere l'unico abitante.
Per la prima volta ho sentito
la città più intima, più accogliente,
una sensazione di appartenenza
che non avevo mai provato prima.
Ecco: in quei momenti ho capito
che il mio intento non è quello
di fotografare ciò che vedo,
o ciò che accade davanti al mio obiettivo;
ma piuttosto, di dare un'immagine
a quello che sento,
a quello che ho dentro.
Questa consapevolezza
mi ha dato una spinta,
una spinta per andare sempre più lontano:
lontano dalla mia casa,
lontano dalla mia città,
verso nuovi luoghi, fisici e mentali,
spesso sconosciuti.
Creando di volta in volta,
attraverso l'obiettivo,
un contatto con la dimensione esterna,
ma contemporaneamente
anche con quella dentro di me.
A vent'anni, poi,
sono cambiate un po’ di cose.
Ho partecipato a un concorso,
ho vinto una borsa di studio
e ho iniziato finalmente
a studiare fotografia,
prima a Roma e poi a New York.
Sentivo, però,
che era arrivato il momento
di aprire un nuovo capitolo.
C'era ancora tanto altro,
da raccontare, e mancava qualcosa.
Forse perché la vita sì,
è fatta di luoghi, sicuramente;
ma anche di persone,
soprattutto di persone.
Così, archiviato il periodo
di studi all'estero,
torno in Italia, nella casa
dove tutto era iniziato,
e decido che era arrivato il momento:
dovevo fotografare la mia famiglia.
In questo nuovo processo creativo,
volevo coinvolgere attivamente
i miei familiari
e lasciarli liberi di esprimersi,
di decidere dove realizzare la fotografia,
cosa indossare e come posare.
Non doveva essere una mia foto:
doveva essere la nostra foto.
La prima che decido
di coinvolgere è mia madre.
Ricordo perfettamente il giorno
in cui abbiamo realizzato
questa fotografia:
eravamo a casa da sole,
e dopo pranzo decidiamo di fare
qualche scatto di prova.
Prendo la macchina fotografica,
la monto sul treppiede,
lei mi suggerisce il punto dove scattare,
io nel frattempo imposto l'inquadratura,
l'esposizione e la messa a fuoco.
Insomma, tutto era pronto,
tutto era deciso:
ma nel momento in cui vado
a scattare la fotografia,
lei mi mette le mani sugli occhi.
Non so perché l'abbia fatto:
istintivamente, mi ha impedito di vedere.
Ecco: quel gesto, quel non vedere,
mi ha aperto gli occhi,
perché mi ha fatto capire,
ancora una volta,
di quanto il contatto
attraverso il mezzo fotografico
sia un contatto estremamente vero,
autentico e vulnerabile
anche quando entrano in gioco
le relazioni con altre persone.
Infatti, la parte più interessante
e preziosa di questo lavoro
è stato il coinvolgimento
che ho ottenuto durante gli scatti,
grazie al quale ho scoperto
degli aspetti sconosciuti
dei miei familiari.
Così mi sono detta:
se scopro tutto questo
di persone che conosco così bene,
cosa potrei mai scoprire
di persone che non conosco affatto?
Ho iniziato a fotografarmi
con degli estranei.
Per estranei intendo persone
che non avevo mai conosciuto
prima di allora,
e questo lavoro ne è stato il pretesto.
Nella fase iniziale,
agli sconosciuti ho consegnato
una macchina fotografica usa e getta,
e chiesto loro di fotografare
tutto quello che sentivano proprio,
tutto quello che li rappresentava.
Successivamente, abbiamo visionato
le fotografie insieme
e deciso come realizzare lo scatto.
Ecco: la fase di progettazione
è stato il momento principale
per entrare in contatto con loro,
che mi ha permesso di capire -
anzi, ci ha permesso di capire -
quali aspetti della loro personalità
volevano rappresentare
attraverso una sola foto.
Di questo lavoro
è stato prezioso il percorso,
che mi ha portato
a vivere un'esperienza autentica,
di quelle che non si vivono
tutti i giorni,
con delle persone
che da totali sconosciute
sono diventate intime
nel giro di pochissimo.
È stato, poi, bello vedere
come quasi tutti loro hanno compreso
di quanto il mezzo fotografico
sia un potente strumento di introspezione,
che può tradurre,
attraverso una sola fotografia,
tanto del proprio essere,
tanto di quello che siamo.
Oggi, guardando indietro il mio percorso,
mi rendo conto di quanto questa ricerca
mi abbia portato lontana dalla mia casa
ad osservare l'esterno, il mondo,
gli affetti, le emozioni, l'altro.
Sento che le mie fotografie
sono cresciute insieme a me,
ma io sono cresciuta
soprattutto grazie a loro.
E non vi parlo di obiettivi,
o successi lavorativi ottenuti,
perché per me la mia conquista più grande
resta quella di aver trovato uno strumento
per entrare in contatto
con la mia dimensione interiore.
E questo mi ha permesso
di conoscermi, crescere,
affrontare delle questioni personali
e trovare il mio posto al mondo.
Oggi più che mai,
in questa confusione di informazioni,
immagini e rumori che ci circondano,
il rischio è proprio quello di perdersi,
e di ritrovarsi a vivere
nell'idea o nell'immagine
di qualcun altro, più che nella nostra.
Per questo penso
che sia estremamente importante
riuscire a trovare un mezzo che ci aiuti
a focalizzare quello che siamo.
Per me, appunto, è la fotografia;
ma è solamente una
di queste tantissime forme.
E se sono qui a raccontarvi tutto questo,
è perché penso che ognuno di noi
ha già questo mezzo dentro di sé.
Deve semplicemente trovare il modo
per dargli una forma.
E per riuscirci, non serve un talento:
serve semplicemente voglia di esplorare.
Ad esempio, se tra di voi c'è qualcuno
che ha l'interesse, e la curiosità,
o anche il bisogno
di iniziare questa ricerca,
be’, permettetemi
di condividere un consiglio
che magari, detto da una fotografa,
può suonare strano:
fate questa ricerca ad occhi chiusi.
Non lasciatevi minimamente influenzare
da quello che vi circonda.
Non fatevi influenzare dalle voci
e dalle esperienze altrui.
Seguite solamente il vostro intuito,
il vostro istinto,
e quello che sentite,
quello che avete dentro.
Perché la risposta è lì, solamente lì.
E un'altra cosa:
cerchiamo di non avere troppa fretta,
perché questa ricerca può avvenire
in qualsiasi momento della vita,
e soprattutto a qualsiasi età.
Non c'è un troppo presto,
e nemmeno un troppo tardi.
L'esplorazione dell'io penso che sia
veramente un viaggio libero,
senza regole e soprattutto senza errori.
Se ripenso alla me bambina,
e a quella strana avversione
per i luoghi bui,
be’, non mi sembra più così strana.
Anzi è la ragione che dà un senso
a tutto questo percorso.
E nel mio piccolo,
ma con grande soddisfazione,
posso dire di aver trasformato
tutti quegli angoli bui
in immagini piene di luce.